when the meeting came hours after Russia
launched a major missile strike on the
Central City of kriviri early on Tuesday
at least 10 people have been reported
dead and dozens injured Jonah Hall
reports from the capital Kiev
the scene is by now familiar only the
location changes
this is crazy Rick in central Ukraine
President Vladimir zielinsky's Hometown
and in the early hours of Tuesday
Morning the target of a Russian missile
strike
I woke up from the first bang a week one
and went straight onto the balcony then
the second explosion roared over my head
and I watched from my balconies the hot
debris fell I looked left and I saw the
first and second entrance were on fire
police body cam footage shows the
chaotic aftermath
survivors escaping a five-story
apartment building struck as they slept
some dazed dozens injured
and many dead
missiles and drones were aimed at
Targets across Ukraine including the
capital Kiev where air defenses were
able to intercept them and as Ukraine
continues it's counter-offensive to
retake occupied territory it is likely
more will come
the defense Ministry says its forces
have made modest advances on three
fronts in the East and towards the South
seven Villages have been taken back it
says including this one makarifka where
the ukrainians admit they faced heavy
resistance
we have liberated the village of
makarivka in the Donetsk region from
Russian forces but they're attempting to
take it back they're using artillery
rocket launchers and tanks but we shall
overcome because we are Marines
Russia tells a different story its
defense Ministry says attacks in
makarifka and the vicinity were repelled
Russian war bloggers published footage
of what they claim a german-made leopard
to tanks and U.S made Bradley Fighting
Vehicles captured near the eastern city
of bakmut
trophies they say of Ukraine's
counter-offensive campaign that has a
long way to run yet
meanwhile Russian the president of
Vladimir Putin says Ukraine has suffered
close to catastrophic losses since the
beginning of its counter-offensive he
made the comments during a meeting with
the Russian war correspondents in Moscow
the counter-offensive is large scale
with the use of reserves prepared for
this it started on June 4th
the structure of their losses is
unfavorable for them what do I mean of
all the losses they are approaching the
assessment which can be called
catastrophic in terms of personnel the
structure of these losses is unfavorable
because the losses can be sanitary or
irrevocable or commentators in Russia
have described the counter-offensive as
a failure so far moscow-based journalist
Euless has more
Russia's top officials have acknowledged
the Ukrainian counter-offensive is
underway they do not comment on
Ukraine's gains and successes but do
admit heavy losses for the Ukrainian
side we see the military activity uh
stretching all along a huge part of the
front line from zapparagia further down
to the South the Russian military
bloggers have called the Ukrainian
attempts a failure but at the Ukrainian
end we hear that they haven't actually
started their proper offensive they're
currently using around 15 to 20 percent
of their reserves testing Russia's
defenses trying to reveal their weak
spots domestically we keep receiving
reports about regular shelling of
Russia's border regions there was a
report by the governor of the Kursk
region of Russia the two border
villagers in the Kursk region were
Sheldon the early morning of June the
13th luckily no casualties were reported
but quite significant damage was caused
as analysts here say while commenting on
Ukraine's actions in light of the
counter-offensive the ukrainians try to
divert Russia's attention to make them
send part of the Russian reserves to
defend those border regions of Russia So
currently it seems like Ukraine can
benefit from the situation but things
quickly change therefore we have just to
wait and see